on profite pas à 6 de sa famille c'est
triste
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
concernant le problème de l'industrie
pharmaceutique là aussi c'était un truc
tout à fait
extraordinaire de voir que
leur haine des civières a été acheté
pour en acheter pour l'europe acheter
pour un milliard d'euros la veille du
jour où l'om est et ne servent à rien
quand même temps que moi si vous me
posez pas de question qu'un truc pareil
on posait jamais quelqu'un qui me dit
écoutez je suis terrifiée par ce vaccin
et j'ai peur d'avoir des effets
secondaires de médecin je dirais coût de
2,2 du vaccin je veux dire écoutez pour
l'instant et tant que vous n'êtes pas
dans une situation épidémique c'est pas
nécessaire voyez donc toi j'ai chaque
personne on dit en fonction moi je crois
au conseil médical et je pense qu'un des
problèmes qu'on a avec le vaccin c'est
que on pense que l'état peut décider à
la place des médecins inquiets de la
situation de chacun moi je crois que la
situation dépend des uns et les autres
si quelqu'un j'ai dit les gens qui sont
les soignants qui sont au contact avec
des gens qui ont un risque d'avoir la
peau vide ils ont beaucoup plus de
raison d'être vaccinées que les autres
[Musique]
à partir du moment où on n'arrive pas
vous avez pas prendre autrement que la
représentation des femmes au travers par
exemple de ce concours miss france est
une représentation où elle est comme un
objet alors on utilise
larry qui jusqu'à ce que madame est
servie donenr le droit à que la société
avant un modèle de société
terrifiant me permets de vous rappeler
quand même que la plainte qui a été
déposée l'a été par trois candidatures
ont été rossés au courant il a refusé en
avant la voix là il n'en demeure pas
moins que vous avez cité le fait que c
est son mal comme des mannequins le
problème c'est que dans le concours
elles ne sont pas traitées comme des
mannequins c'est à dire qu'elles n'ont
pas de contrat de travail qui les
protège d'une exploitation non meilleur
d'entre eux
va arriver tout seul comme ça du jour au
lendemain vous expliquez
vous parlez tous vu de l'extérieur donc
effectivement je vous parle vu de
l'intérieur il ya une préparation de 1
mois
est ce que vous savez tous les cadeaux
qu'on reçoit mais c'est bien des filles
qui n'ont jamais pris l'avion on va dans
des destinations de rêve on est hyper
heureuse tous les soirs on a un petit
cadeau sur le lit où on est vraiment
gâté et ça ça n'a pas de valeur et
l'expérience miss france n'a pas de
valeur c'est une personne par région par
année rien que ça c'est c'est
fantastique et toutes les jeunes filles
va sentais que j'avais l'intention
d'obliger sens que je suis de gamme ça
rêve de faire ça et ça ça n'a pas de
valeur si maintenant vous dites ok je
pose 5000 euros ce matin pour participer
à miss france c'est impossible donc rien
que ça voyez vous voyez la beauté des
poussins me regarde et vois le sexisme
qui émane de ce que vous dites alors oui
l'idée que le mister france
ils reçoivent les mêmes canaux et ils
ont été considérés comme étant en étant
soumis en droit du travail
le drame qui avec magali berda sida il
ya un peu plus de dix jours dans la nuit
du 9 au 10 octobre dernier karine votre
belle soeur et son compagnon ont été
sauvagement assassinés dans leur
appartement près de marseille lors de
corps ont été retrouvés par une des
filles de la victime qu'est ce qui s'est
passé en fait au départ elles n'ont pas
de nouvelles de leur maman et les filles
ont cherché à joindre la famille enfin à
joindre leur part leur mère et leur beau
pays qu'est ce qui s'est passé elles ont
cherché à joindre à ma belle-soeur et
et pas de nouvelles donc à sont allés
sur place et julie a trouvé sa mère et
son ami par terre avec un drap sur
reposée et une scène assez compliqué et
ses deux petites soeurs attendait sur
sur le parking donc on a entendu crier
donc les petites soeurs sont montés
également et julie a crié et le voisin
aujourd'hui julien de 24 ans s'est
replié à 24 la plus grande et je les
embrasse parce qu'elle nous regarde là
et
le voisin est sortie n'est sorti en plus
donc il l'a prise dans ses bras elle
s'est mise à hurler lorsqu'elle a
découvert la scène hélas le voisin qui
aujourd'hui le meurtrier présumé sort et
la prononcer brassac et donc c'est le
voisin qui est le meurtrier présumé qui
sort en entendant les cris en fait elle
était sur lui comme si elle a vu
quelqu'un que sortir dans qu'elle a
cherchés venait de quoi donc ea s'est
jeté sur lui et l'a prise dans ses bras
et après il est rentré dans son
appartement à lui en disant qu'ils
pouvaient pas voir il faisait comme s'il
avait peur qu'il était je peux pas
regarder ça je peux pas voir ça et il
est rentré dans son appartement
la pauvre combat subi des bacs d'un ceux
des vagues dun sud quotidiennement à
cause de ces stratégies dans l'émission
c'est vrai qu'on est passé d'un jeu koh
lanta à une guerre sur les réseaux
sociaux on a l'impression que c'est un
truc de fou elle s'en prendre plein la
gueule la profonde pour combat
d'ailleurs il sera avec nous
est ce qu'avec tous les deux le sort de
leur mode ça
qu'est-ce qu'ils sont cons mais pas pour
rigoler c'est
[Rires]
vraiment oui c'est vraiment mais c'est
pareil mais en tout cas être combat sera
avec nous la crèche est super c'est
content de l'avoir aventurière et dort
sur un recap est en débat des gâtés
question
oui alors toi les patois allez on a un
recap on en débat juste après avec
fabien lecoeuvre qui avait été victime
de menaces de mort à la suite d'un
dérapage sur la chanteuse aux chips avec
l'arrivée d'internet et des réseaux
sociaux aujourd'hui n'importe qui peut
envoyer un message sous couvert
d'anonymat pour lever leur anonymat il
faut un huissier il faut engager une
procédure judiciaire c'est une démarche
fastidieuse les plateformes comme
facebook twitter ou instagram se sont
donc transformés en véritables déversoir
de haine pour certains ou bas candidate
emblématique de koh lanta on a fait les
frais récemment en recevant des messages
d'une extrême violence enfin tant que
personnalité publique entre guillemets
je me dois de dénoncer ce genre de
comportement qui est illégal qui allait
décider de porter plainte elle n'est pas
un cas isolé il ya le club lui aussi
avec les victimes de menaces après avoir
fait une déclaration maladroite
concernant la chanteuse au chili à
plusieurs mois quand vous regardez
o'shea elle est effrayante il avait
pourtant tenu à s'excuser mais
l'harcèlement n'a jamais cessé moi j'ai
beaucoup de peine de tout ça parce que
je voulais pas faire ça vous qui me
connaissaient depuis des années c'est
pas mon métier de ce coup d'insultés
légende c'est pas votre style c'est pas
bout de six ou non mais bien sûr bien
sûr j'aime utiliser le move est synonyme
c'est une erreur je l'ait reconnu je
m'en suis excusé ce que je craignais de
la concept non mais moi ce que je
regrette justement cyril c'est ça c'est
l'absence de dialogue oui mais elle peut
pas elle a été par moments on peut la
même prendre bien sûr quelle a été ma
bien c'est très dur et les mêmes noms
mais bien sûr bien sûr mais et cdh a
contacté vais pas vous parler non
mélangés à comprendre la peau non mais
j'ai pas essayé de la contacter d'utada
corner passédat contraints de devoir
avoir de la peine pour l'attaquant et
moi ça me fait chier clairement parce
que à un moment donné là c'est quand
même toi l'attaquant fabien c'est toi
qui as attaquant volontairement
involontairement mais quand même ça t'es
pas débile tu as quand même dit des mots
je dormais laisser des mots très forts
sinon j'aurais aimé ce que j'aurais
simplement aimé c'est qu'en fait
celui-là contact et tu fasse tout pour
essayer de la joindre et que tu
t'excuses devant elle pas trop fait ou
dit si tu utilises encore les réseaux
pour excuser ce père contourneront
espère que c'est que les réseaux les
réseaux les réseaux et après la cellule
ya un même âge un juge pas les raisons
mais aussi parce que tu t'excuses
publiquement sur les réseaux mais non
non non ça sortir des réseaux il faut se
mettre dans la vraie vie etc s'excuser
dans la vraie vie ça c'est parce que les
gars la vraie vie c'est ce qui compte le
plus
j'ai reçu d'aidé peut-être vraiment des
milliers de messages de gens victimes
mais deux choses comme ça j'en ai reçu
des tonnes et je peux vous garantir que
la force aujourd'hui je vais avoir sur
les réseaux sociaux je la mettrai toute
ma vie dans ce combat là vraiment combat
développement poche a gagné vous êtes
traumatisés aujourd'hui je suis pas
traumatisé il fut triste car c'est
normal oui je suis triste parce que je
me dis qu'on a loupé les choses parce
que je me dis que on profite pas si de
sa famille c'est triste ça me fait de la
peine pour ma belle famille mais pas
assez pour citer deux
votre conjoint et ça me ferait pas une
pour médias stéphanie les îles et pas
vraiment pas bien il est vraiment pas
bien on est plein de remords on est
plein de quadro morts c'est comme ça
cela-dit est juste je pourrais pas que
c'était connu déclare fou parce que
c'est de toute manière pour tuer
quelqu'un il faut être givré mais oui
donc de toute manière il faut être fou
donc quand on tue c'est qu'on est fous
donc ça n'excuse pas il n'y a plus rien
qui peut excuser ça on a enlevé une
maman de trois petites filles ou alors
ils avaient de bons motifs pour le faire
mais dans ce cas là
on saura où alors il est fou il n'y a
pas d'alternative faut être fou pour
tuer le foutoir donc de toute manière on
y fera fou il est fou donc il faut qu'il
soit jugé donc je ne je ne lâcherai rien
là dessus
[Musique]
côté boulot
tu es reculer
gauthier vous étiez devant eric zemmour
lorsqu'il a mis en joue les journalistes
racontez nous la scène qui s'est passé
ça fait énormément parler en fait eh
bien c'était au tout début de sa visite
au salon milipol donc on l'a vu il il
teste un sniper qui est utilisé entre
autres par le raid concernant vous êtes
senti en danger ou pas du tout mais non
absolument pas à aucun moment on savait
très bien que l'armée était déchargée ça
a duré quelques secondes n'ont à aucun
moment je me suis senti en danger ou
menacés monsieur van tourneau pointe une
arme sur personne
en moyenne sur personne deuxièmement ça
va quand même dans un bain écouter
excusez moi oui mais non mairie alors
non je suis moi c'est pas ça c'est pas
votre ce que vous dites c'est vous
[Rires]
deuxièmement c'est pas innocent si même
pas ouvert d'humour il pointe et
journalistes alors qu'il vient de là
troisièmement je pose une question si
c'était pas zemmour mais un musulman qui
pour rire
[Applaudissements]
isabelle isabelle il avait
les abeilles l'occupent tobin bell et la
campagne [ __ ] en anglais il ya encore
six mois c'est sûr si chaque fois on
sort à chaque fois choqué non parce
qu'on voit bien qu'il tient le fusil
comme ça il le tournoi
[Musique]
n'a rien à voir
j'avais tweet de marlène créer du coup
une vraie c'est possible et c'est une
vraie séquence politique parce que
derrière évidemment que tout le monde va
reprendre les arguments ou de marlène
schiappa en disant ils cherchent à
mettre au pas la presse en europe sous
coups d'humour etc et de l'autre côté on
aura un argumentaire politique en réseau
vous venez me parler de ça mais je veux
la lumière ça me choque pas parce que
c'est eric zemmour il fait du eric
zemmour c'est à dire de la provocation
et puis au delà de la blague c'est quand
même une image qui symbolise la guerre
entre eric zemmour et certains
journalistes certains police m'a défoncé
amis mais ça vous allez gagner vous et
c'est à paul et ça a duré trois secondes
mais ce n'est quand même pas choquer les
journalistes au hasard marlène schiappa
riche et porsche a prévalu dans une
joute avec les mêmes qu'avec les
homosexuels qui ont des enfants
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
non mais non merci non pas à
l'e3 technique de l'âge pour larguer tam
up ou ton mec apte à battre alors je ne
t'aime plus honteux là je lâche à
comprendre
[Applaudissements]
vers 12h
tu vois rien chaque fois tu sais ce qui
est déjà
tombé à 6 t3 tue l'amour pt au lit alors
n'a pas dit ce qu'on parlait pas qu'elle
se trompe et prénom oui se trouve être
ou non non non
[Applaudissements]
we have ou trois choses que tu cries
pendant le sexe non un an
attention pas pu
être atteint
d
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]